sommes en direct avec florian philippot
le président des patriotes florian
philippot bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur arte france peut être un
mot sur la mobilisation cet après midi
on l'a lu beaucoup de monde entre la
place de la république et la place de la
bastille ça vous étonne non ça ne
m'étonne pas il ya effectivement
beaucoup de monde je crois si vous les
clefs bon les gens étaient évidemment
choqués par ces images sur la sphère
michel est clair mais au-delà de ça je
pense qu'il ya un espèce de ras-le-bol
gigantesque du peuple français d'être
maltraité depuis plusieurs années c'est
très difficile aujourd'hui de manifester
quand on est dans l'opposition je veux
je peux vous le dire comme chef de parti
politique j'en sais quelque chose quand
même à avoir l'autorisation de
manifester face à chaque fois c'est la
galère de plus en plus souffert des
référés anormal et les français sentent
bien cela ils ont dû évidemment déjà du
temps des gilet jaune mais je rappelle
aussi les manifs de pompiers en janvier
2020 ou des ponts qui avait été tabassé
des infirmières également les manifs
retraite il manif loi travail à chaque
fois il ya eu des duels des brutalités
qui sont pas absolument pas admissible
est de pire en pire
et donc je crois que les français en ont
ras-le-bol alors ça s'ajoute évidemment
à l'ambiance actuelle du dictature
sanitaire si vous voulez vous devez
remplir un bout de papier pour avoir le
droit de sortir de chez vous depuis des
mois on a des couvre-feux déconfinement
à répétition et des interdictions
absolument partout vous y ajoutez la loi
sécurité globale avec ses drones etc
l'interdiction de filmer ses ébats vous
avez quelque chose de très cohérent
c'est que le peuple la france et n'est
plus une démocratie et que les français
dans leurs gènes eux dans leur adn
politique
ils sont très attachés à la liberté à
leurs libertés individuelles leur
liberté collective et donc c'est normal
qu'ils se fassent enfants alors florian
philippot vrai ça avec nous je vous
propose d'écouter jean pierre colombiès
l'ancien commandant de police il était
avec nous tout à l'heure il réagissait
aux propos
du préfet de police didier lallement qui
est qui demandait si nalement à ses
policiers de garder une ligne
républicaine je vous propose d'écouter
jean pierre colombiès qui réagissent et
j'aimerais pas être à la place ni des
hommes qui sont sur le terrain ni de la
hiérarchie intermédiaire qui va des
commandes et parce qu'il est évident que
il y a un trouble particulier dans les
instructions qui leur sont données
puisque rappelez vous le préfet de
police tué m'avait dit qu'on entrait
dans une dynamique de contact qu'il
fallait au le contact qu'il fallait
fallait pas hésiter à faire mal
c'est ça que ça veut dire un fauve au
pouvoir était de tourner autour du
pauvre quand on vous dit à des forces de
police aller au contact n'hésitez pas à
utiliser la force strictement nécessaire
voire au delà
faut pas s'étonner après qu'on ait des
images et des images catastrophiques
comme on a l'habitude de les voir
et puis vous avez aussi la tentation
évidente est logique d'une tentative de
récupération politique qui d'ailleurs
récupération politique c'est peut-être
bien inspiré d'avoir elle aussi une
ligne philosophique clair et net
parce que vous savez vous échappera pas
que les manifestations prennent
quasiment systématiquement une tournure
violente ces derniers temps mais tout
simplement parce que la population
probablement peut-être c'est une
interrogation qu'on peut avoir
ne trouve plus auprès des relais
politiques traditionnels conventionnelle
l'appui qu'elle mériterait peut-être
d'avoir florian philippon quand le
préfet l'allemand écrit une lettre aux
policiers en leur demandant de tenir la
ligne républicaine comment est ce que
vous comprenez ses mots non m et
finalement du parti aurait dû être
débarqués plus exactement depuis bien
longtemps
tu dire ce qui s'est passé et il était
là avec les manifestations de gilet
jaune on se souvient des yeux crevés des
mains arrachées et c'est alors réduit
entraîné le sa disqualification son
limogeage depuis bien longtemps or je
constate que les ministres de
l'intérieur passe mais que le préfet de
police ne trace pas je sais pas ce qu'il
ya sous 50 casquette mais il doit y
avoir quelque chose d'extraordinaire de
fabuleux parce qu'il est surprotégé or
son bilan est objectivement
catastrophique est accablant donc si
vous voulez le
c'est finalement il doit partir bon ça
réglera pas le problème je pense qu'un
piège dans cette affaire c'est de
d'ivoire s'ils voulaient notamment entre
alone à la à l'aune de la sphère michel
des éclairs qui est elle même
scandaleuse mais d'ivoire simplement
soit un problème de police pour d'autres
populations voire de racisme structurel
d'une partie de la police c'est
peut-être vers ce chemin que certains
vont essayer de nous emmener un
maquereau lui même dans son truc il
parle tout de suite de racisme et puis
les comités traoré black l'animateur etc
ces choses là mais peut-être essayer de
nous emmener là cette vision des choses
binaire alors en disant il ya un
problème simplement d'une partie de la
police nationale avec du racisme ce que
tu as comme ça on se donne le beau rôle
ou dit c'est juste un problème de
sélection de formation des policiers
c'est un problème de racisme
et puis macro est du bon côté de la
barrière il est du côté du bien
non je crois qu'il ya un problème
beaucoup plus général qui est un poème
d'état autorités un petit état au
service d'une un petit état du
aujourd'hui le ski n'est plus souverain
un petit état mafieux au service d'une
petite caste qui utilise l'état et la
police à son service exclusif pour
maintenir son pouvoir et son emprise sur
le peuple français je pense que c'est ça
le problème est donc ça c'est une
responsabilité politique
fondamentalement mais vous voyez bien
que si on a cet analyste politique là
alors on peut mettre la police et la
gendarmerie
du côté du peuple français parce que la
majorité refusera de la division avec le
peuple français
selon vous c'est toute la scène loi
sécurité globale qui doit être retiré ou
alors seulement cet article 24
au début c'était celui-là qui posait
problème on en parlait beaucoup non
c'est toute la loi cette loi n'apporte
rien face à ce qui pourrit la vie de
beaucoup de français au quotidien sur la
délinquance la criminalité du quotidien
sai a rien dans la loi pour aider les
français de ce point de vue là c'est là
dessus qu'il faudrait les aider il ya la
criminalité de la délinquance en france
des trafics et star ac 5 devrait cibler
et c'est là c'est là dessus qu'on
devrait aider les policiers qui font
face à beaucoup de difficultés parce que
c'est pas facile mais dans la loi
sécurité globale c'est pas ça c'est une
loi de surveillance générale et à
l'article 24
on a beaucoup parlé l'article 22 n'est
pas mal non plus avec ses drones qui
peuvent aller surveiller les
manifestations vous prendre en photo
vous filmer ça fait furieusement penser
à du fichage syndicale
ce politique et c'est absolument
inadmissible qu'il ya même le nom a le
même look sécurité globale qui est un
espèce d'aspe un peu inquiétant
l'ascendant le nom de cette loi dont il
faut supprimer cette loi ça réglera pas
tout parce que s'ils voulaient même si
demain on supprime cette loi on aura
toujours de petits bouts de papiers à
remplir nouvelle pour avoir le droit de
sortir de chez nous on aura toujours des
couvre-feux sans en avoir sans avoir
d'issue de sortie du couvre feu
on aura toujours ce masque qu'on nous
impose à l'extérieur sans savoir quelle
légitimité scientifique sa cible donc
des destins des mesures d'emprise sur de
liberté individuelle
donc c'est vraiment une révolution
politique et philosophique
on doit coopérer et on ne peut pas la
faire avec des macros et des darnes en
est quand le chef de l'état justement de
demande au gouvernement de faire des
propositions pour réaffirmer le lien de
confiance entre les français et les
policiers comment vous le comprenez pour
vous par où ça doit passer
donc je n'y crois plus du tout à tout
cela on l'a déjà entendu on l'a des gens
donc ça n'a jamais rien donné
je pense que nous avons en civil et la
réalité a les politiques nous avons à la
tête de l'état des gens qui font peu de
cas de la liberté individuelle de la
démocratie et qui considèrent que un peu
leur peuple comme du bétail qu'on doit
gérer et non plus d'un peuple de
citoyens éclairés qu'on doit respecter
pour ba écoute et qu'on doit suivre ce
qui est normalement à des moutons la
démocratie la définition même de la
démocratie
donc si les jeunes fellation pas
confiance à ces gens là et etc
ils sont dans une dérive oligarchique
elisson dans une vieille de casse et est
donc tout ce qu'il dira on dansera
hypocrite et tout ce qu'ils feront lira
dans le mauvais sens ça s'ils l'ont
démontré de trois ans et demi il n'y a
aucune raison qu'ils changent jaune
alors on voit sur ces images d'un des
tensions des casseurs là
un homme habillé de noir qui est en
train de casser une voiture à l'instant
certains particulièrement plutôt à
droite il a craint que ces
manifestations soient instrumentalisées
par l'extrême gauche
c est que ça vire à la juste à la haine
anti-flic quel est votre sentiment
mais ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est si vous l'essayez c'est que
effectivement le npa ce qu'est devenue
la france est soumise aujourd'hui sos
racisme le comité traoré est ce que j'ai
vu kassa traoré évidemment il était vont
essayer de transformer tout ça en un
truc juste anti raciste et anti flics
ben je pense que ça c'est ce qu'a le
pire c'est qu'on va diviser le peuple
français à l'horizontale si vous voulez
voit bien diviser les gens entre eux
entre noirs et blancs entre policiers et
population
et alors que le combat il doit être
vertical tout son centre contre
l'oligarchie
voilà donc est alors bien sûr là dedans
vous avez les inévitables les éternels
black blocks antifa casseurs c'est un
peu près tous le même groupe qui arrange
bien le gouvernement et qui pourrissent
la vie par ailleurs des policiers et des
manifestants
voyez tous ensemble donc faut pas tomber
dans ces manipulations l'a vraiment pas
trouvé l'ancienne manipulation là et ne
comptez pas sur le besancenot assata
aurait cette engeance pour défendre les
bonnes causes ils n'ont jamais défendu
les bonnes causes ils ont toujours fait
en sorte de diviser le peuple français
quand il fallait être unie au contraire
contre nous mettre encore dans le car on
le voit on dirait que tu sais sur ces
images une voiture qui est en train de
prendre feu en plein cortège de la
manifestation contre la loi sécurité
globale florian philippot une
manifestation en pleine affaire michel
est clair vous le rappeliez du nom de ce
producteur passé à tabac par plusieurs
policiers
le chef de l'état a fait part de sa
honte on l'aviron le disait beaucoup de
monde aujourd'hui dans les rues en
pleine crise sanitaire
est ce que le gouvernement pourrait
reculer en tout cas est ce qu'il y a
suffisamment d'éléments réunies pour que
le gouvernement recule sur ce projet de
loi aujourd'hui
oui sauf si vraiment normalement ils
devraient reculer mais en même temps je
pense qu'ils ont tellement à coeur de
contrôler la population et d'un de 2,2
soul et d'intimider les futurs
mouvements populaires parce que parce
que le peuple français risque au
gouvernement de se soulever que ils ont
peut-être besoin quand même de ces
drones et et de ces interdictions et de
cette loi sécurité globale qui vont
certainement essayer de tenir par des
artifices et la question est assez forte
ceci dit parfois là dans d'autres cas la
question a été forte et les
gouvernements n'ont pas reculé beaucoup
faut quand même accentuer les flops en
tout cas là où l'on peut aussi reculer
quand je vois les images et lui le monde
collés les uns aux autres et jan aps
l'argent évidemment sans masque et je ne
les blâme pas ce n'est pas du tout ça
fait partie de la vie en tout cas ça
devrait amener le gouvernement à reculer
sur la fermeture des restaurants des
bars lit toute l'histoire de 30
personnes à la nes et de six personnes
autour de la table à noël en voile c'est
ridicule quand on est en train de voir
on voit dans cette manifestation ou bien
aucun aucune règle sanitaire qui n'est
plus respectée et peut-être parce que
les gens ont envie simplement de vivre
on voit des images qui vont également
peut-être sucer susciter encore des
interrogations à l'international ah oui
mais ça la force je crois qu'en ce
moment elle suscite beaucoup
d'interrogations à l'international vous
savez ya un journal allemand die zeit
qui a parlé récemment récemment de la
thur distant autoritaire français va y
aller de autoritaire basse c'est ce que
conteste beaucoup de manifestants
aujourd'hui cette dérive autoritaire
d'un état et de l'autre côté l'absurde
distant avec les règles incroyable en
france des stations de ski sans
remontées mécaniques des rangs ou à
lille qui tourne mais sans cliente
voilà on y est en plein dedans et ça
effectivement à l'étranger je pense que
on a hâte de retrouver la france n'a
bret qui n'est pas celle qu'on voit
depuis des années merci florian
philippot président
patriote d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france on va